jorian bonjour et merci d'être en direct
avec nous pour cette commandite en
pénultième émission je crois c'est comme
ça move alors engrenage auront ils tous
survivre là et c'est l'avant-dernier en
tout cas d'émission et merci d'être en
direct et vous êtes le principal et non
seulement le principal mais l'unique
éviter la démission après quoi vous
écouterez isabelle motrot dans sa parano
chronique avec une actualité en ce qui
me concerne rien assez forte comme on
dit puisqu'il ya un tir groupé de trois
films du mois sortir sortie en france ce
sont les hasards de la distribution qui
font comment dirais-je télescope et
belle maman et viennent de l'aca siens
et je règle mon pas sur le pas de mon
père oui parce que c'est pas les mêmes
sans sais rien je suppose que ce ne sont
pas les mêmes distributeurs et qu'
il en sort pas pendant deux ans et puis
d'un seul coup ils en sortiront en même
temps vous les avez vus non je les vois
toujours par par morceaux par petits
bouts jojo je vois des bouts de
cassettes et la plupart du temps quand
pour les voir en entier chez dans
l'avion même si un certain délai vous
les voyez pas tout de suite alors c'est
assez rapide y'a pas je crois qu'il ya
pas les impératifs la chronologie de la
télévision il n'ya pas les impératifs de
la télévision ou des chaînes cryptées
que dans les avions ça sort très
rapidement enfin bon il faut prendre
beaucoup avions oui ça fait cher la
place au cinéma quand même mais
généralement dans les avions tous vos
films n'ont pas les chances de passer
d'une façon générale il ya des critères
très faux paquets de mer trop paquet de
sa famille violent maintenant il ya tout
un tas de choses parce que maintenant
dans les avions et un choix on peut
passer d'un truc à l'autre et non non ça
c'est il faut pas que je crois que dans
les avions le seul impératif c'est qui
est pas de film sur les détournements
d'avions sur les catastrophes aériennes
ça oui non vos parts miné le public mais
on peut montrer un bout de simple
montrer une guerre
des arabes et pendant que vous allez
c'est sûr que pour aller au koweit il
vaut mieux pas montrer le film qui passe
le samedi soir canal+ comme c'est arrivé
par erreur un jour où le type s'était
trompé dans l'aiguillage mais autrement
non dans les avions commencent à être à
peu près vous auriez vous n'allez pas au
cinéma par dans les avions je crois non
ça vous ennuie
c'est pas que ça m'ennuie j'aime pas
beaucoup être dans le public je vais
quelquefois au cinéma pour voir des
projections privées mais j'aime pas
beaucoup aidé dans des grandes salles
alors qu'il ya beaucoup de gens du
spectacle qui aime bien être dans des
grandes salles avec 600 personnes mais
moi non le papier de bonbon les gens qui
remuent les gens qui toussent vraiment
c'est pas mon c'est pas mon truc mais
dans les avancées ou peut avoir saboté
et en bulles dans les avions et les
écouteurs et puis ça sur mon petit écran
un média clan à cristaux liquides ouais
c'est pas terrible comme image quand
même ça fait rien c'est dès l'instant
que ces prêts et qu'on en dispose comme
on laisse penser que moi je préfère la
voir les cassettes la plupart du temps
quand je fais des trucs on me donne des
cassettes alors d'abord bon c'est un peu
prétentieux mais c'est vrai j'ai un une
installation ty de télévision qu'est
tech est très bonne j'ai un grand écran
j'ai la stéréo les deux tatas truc donc
je regarde ça tranquillement si un truc
que j'ai pas bien vu je peux rembobinez
regardez donc ces jeux pas dans les
conditions du du spectacle public et vos
propres films vous les voyez comme ça
vous n'avez pas une curiosité très forte
juste après le montage final pour le
jean n'est pas du tout de toute seule
son c'est le contraire j'ai aucune
curiosité pour le film un point sur tous
les autres surtout les miens je sais
quoi parce que vous êtes votre premier
critique vous êtes très que non parce
que ce que je crois que il faut pas tout
le temps vivre là dedans comme
les gens qui sont des peintres qui
reprennent leurs toiles pendant 15 ans
et qui rajoute des trucs et qui cherche
à les racheter qui vont les rechercher
chez les gens pour un couple entend
changer une oreille dans le plat
conséquent
il faut faire moi je si vous avez quand
je parle de cinéma j'ai tout cas de même
des bouts de mes filles je jamais
dissocier gérard
important à cette maison mais je veux
dire et avec gérard on avait vraiment
envie de faire des choses périssables on
n'avait pas envie que ça reste on
faisait difficile voisin qu'on soignait
pas beaucoup les choses qu'on faisait
parce qu'on avait un comportement
artistique de deux
techniques du briquet jetable
faut pas attendrir sur un sur un briquet
en plastique qui vous qui coûte quatre
fois inquiets qui fait pour pas
s'obstiner à leur charge et habib fekih
à la plupart des accidents sont des gens
qui achètent des briquets jetables qui
font des trous dedans pour les recharger
quand même
vous me l'apprenez alors il ya des tas
de gens qui c'est pas normal il est vide
et on a une bombe machin va pouvoir
installer un petit trou est un trou avec
a clos il met le vin il faut ici sont
exposées dans le vif cela dit j'ai un
type que je connais qui travaille au
musée de l'homme qui a été tout à fait
en ethnologue tout à fait intéressants
et importants dont je n'irai pas le nom
qui est parti faire une mission en
afrique et il avait des gros problèmes
d'humidité avec ses appareils photos on
lui a dit mais pourquoi tu es tu prends
pas les appareils jetables il a dit oui
c'est très bien il a pris l'appareil il
a pris les photos il ajouté alors vous
fait de la vente est
très bien à venir vers vous
mais vous pensez sérieusement que les
fils d'une façon générale sont des
objets jetables non je pense qu'il ya
déjà dans les chefs-d'oeuvre non je dis
pas que c'est ce que tout le monde doit
faire ça je dis nous n'avions pas
l'intention nous de faire des films
qu'ils destinaient a duré 15 ans ou 20
ans où nous 50 ans certains ont survécu
bon parce que c'était le témoin d'une
époque d'un certain nombre d'événements
il ya des gens qui font des films qui
sont des films pour fait toujours
pourquoi et pour qui les diffusent plus
tard dans les stations spatiales et
cette notion de films pas trop soigné
parce que ça va pas trop dur et y est
vous avez quand même d'épigones suis
versé c'est jean pierre mocky oui bah
c'est pas c'est un peu ça sauf qu'il
naquit penta les phénomènes de société
aussi
encore si le fait oui c'est à dire que
le problème du soin apporté aux au film
si vous voulez traiter des phénomènes
d'actualité on peut pas fignoler pendant
des années et monteiro montée surmonter
et puis et puis les sorties repas que
les gens s'en rappellent plus sur un peu
plus de l'événement de base qui a servi
à ça il faut trouver des sujets
permanent pourra voir des films dont on
fignole entend la honte je parle aux
gens yann comédiens on reviendra aux
gentianes la metteur en scène que vous
avez été que vous ça peut être à nouveau
vous allez me le dire mais de l'organe
comédiens et les bons du premier coup et
où vous supportez aisément qu'on fasse
20 30 prises comme mon ami francis veber
qui vit d'ailleurs le sort ges comme
vous je suis meilleur du premier coup
comme tout le monde mais je dire je
crois que ça c'est une chose qui
qui est
difficile à expliquer un metteur en
scène qui ne se sent pas bien du premier
coup car en fait
moi je suis bien du premier coup c'est
lui que pas mon premier coup
quelqu'un une question d abel peu trop
bien sûr du x 50 x hausse mais c'est
toujours beaucoup moins bien
c'est la phrase rituelle du metteur en
scène mais coco c'est parfait on va la
refaire comment expliquez vous ça c'est
l' angoisse non c'est parce que il faut
que tout soit bien et c'est jamais bien
coppola avait fait une expérience tout à
fait extraordinaire à ce trio los
angeles il avait dit je voudrais que mes
films plaisent aux enfants donc par
conséquent il avait pris aux morts qui
étaient chargés de dans une petite
camionnette enfin notre cas où il y
avait des trucs vidéo de choisir chacun
les images qui leur plaisait le mieux
pour arriver à faire un montage qui
était le montage de l'unanimité ensemble
tout cas du de la majorité et puis quand
le camp de truc était finie estime
maintenant on va tourner pour de vrai
ils ont tourné pour de vrai et le
problème s'est reposé qu'il fallait
reçoit zir danse qui venait d'être
tournée donc on n'en finirait plus on
pourront lorsque vous tournez vous même
joyal lorsque l'été metteur en scène de
show-business moyenne à vouloir des sous
tout le monde il est beau tout le monde
il est gentil c'est vous faisiez
beaucoup de prix faisait voûte repris
mais ça dépend avec qui c'était dire ya
des moments où ou quand on est avec des
acteurs qui sont des acteurs avec une
forte personnalité qui rajoute des trucs
c'est devient plaisir d'en demander une
autre parce qu'on sait qu'il fera pas la
même c'est ce héros par exemple vous
pouvez vous prendre 8 bis prise de ce
héros il ya pas eu huit prises pareil
donc à ce moment là c'est tout à fait
différent du bâtiment il m'a fait cette
version là on lui demande en faire une
autre puis après on verra blier c'est la
même chose billet était un type qui
pouvait faire
dix fois la même chose mais s'était
jamais pareil vous l'avez bien exploité
es blessé tu es le le patron qui était
ans qui rentrait des syndicats laisser
votre agence
et les puis le patron de la radio
annonce était
messieurs les terres de la radio n'avale
pas ton temps mais blier lui si vous
voulez je mange toujours été très très
bernard billes c'est très lié avec lui
et les reconnaissant parce qu'il est le
premier qui a accepté de faire le mon
premier film et que ça et c'est
difficile quand on fait un premier film
c'était quoi tout le monde il est beau
c'est encore but if plus difficile quand
on est acteur parce que où qu'on a fait
autre chose dans le spectacle c'était
c'est votre film qui est fait je crois
le plus de succès si on part en termes
d'entraînement ben on va dire d'entrée
paris et d'entrée surprise oui pas
d'entrée au total parce qu'à l'époque
moi je travaillais dans une station de
radio périphérique donc par conséquent
sac c'est une station qui sera du côté
de l'avenue montaigne un une station
belle chanteuse du côté là du montet et
n'a jamais y donnant une station disons
dont le l'idée et repose sur le paradis
fiscal c'est pas vrai en plus
ça finit par un
passage
avait une chance sur deux vous trompez
isabelle motrot ces faits et alors le le
problème c'est comme je travaillais dans
cette dans cette chaîne n'est ce pas
dans cette radio j'étais un peu connue
d'une ligne qui allait de bordeaux à
chamanique ce n'est pas du tout dans le
midi ah oui c'est l'époque des grands
noms n'est pas dans le midi donc en fait
on a fait un gros succès dans la moitié
nord de la france mais dans le midi pas
trop
effectivement vous étiez à la fois
l'intérêt à l'extérieur ça a été mal vu
de critiques et de l'intérieur le
système des radios privées
vous savez le système des radios privées
il a pas changé c'est toujours la même
chose sauf que on a on commence à
admettre maintenant que qui a des
combines publicitaire parce que
publicité remake combine alors donc tout
le monde se dit bon bah voilà au départ
c'était surtout saluer c'est à dire mais
la véritable idée lever un véritable
raison pour laquelle j'avais fait un
film sur la radio c'est que comme
c'était mon premier je voulais pas je
voulais être sûr de ce que je
connaissais déjà on a gagné gc par
exemple j'ai dessiné des corps pourquoi
parce que je connaissais par coeur les
tutos mais vous avez encore tsonga
n'avait rien du tout il n'y avait pas du
tout problème n'est pas de risque
en 99 on parle donc encore de ce film
qui était un peu un film emblématique
quand on est maintenant ça va parce que
lille était périssables à perez avant
les passants réparation l'a fait
périssables oui mais on l'a pour la
pensée périssables en disant bon bah si
ça veut raconter un épisode de la vie de
la radio et puis après on s'en fout on
va dénoncer deux trois trucs qu'on
connaît d'abord si t'es pas bien méchant
il rit pas on va dénoncer deux trois
trucs bon et puis après l'actualité a
fait que ça a été pire que ce qu'on
avait raconté donc du coup on est rentré
en on est rentrés dans la dans la dans
la sphère des films promet ni toi est-ce
que c'était un film de revanche parce
que vous avez été virés de partout viré
de toutes les radios
[Musique]
mais non mais non j'ai eu de temps en
temps un certain nombre de problèmes
avec des gens dans les directions ça
tenait pas tellement à la direction des
radios ça tenait plus au fait que dans
le temps les hommes politiques
intervenait
avec gérard on a travaillé ici la france
inter on nous a nous a pas prié de
partir on nous a pas repris en septembre
est en fait
mais en fait on nous a pas pris en
septembre pour une raison simple c'est
qu'on avait enfin moi j'avais dit non
j'avais parlé de la légion d'honneur et
j'avais eu
une phrase malheureuse je sais pas si
maintenant elle est toujours aussi
malheureux jeudi la légion d'honneur
c'est comme les hémorroïdes n'importe
quel trou du cul peut la voir et
évidemment l'amiral kabbani et grand
chancelier de la légion d'honneur j'ai
pas pourquoi ils étaient en train
d'écouter ça ou quelqu'un avait écouté
et on a téléphoné en disant écoutez ce
pas possible que sur les ondes
nationales type tiennent des propos
comme ça sur les joueurs mais vous
n'êtes pas quelques problèmes avec power
au ccap et poète jules président du
sénat soit regretté président c'est lui
c'est lucette c'est cette même chose
parce que c'était c'était à l'époque il
assurait l'intérim de georges pompidou
donc par conséquent il y avait
donc c'est à lui qu'on s'adressait mais
vous n'avez pas dit autre chose
maintenant j'ai pas dit autre chose sur
power j'ai dit que j'avais rencontrés
pour air dans un clac où il était à
quatre pattes en train de manger dans
une écuelle avec une dame qui disait
alors sale chien tu as faim et tout bon
donc par conséquent c'était vrai c'était
pas du tout le problème c'est que
c'était vrai la preuve c'est pas qu'il
avait inventé ce truc là mais évidemment
bon je vais raconter cent mille fois et
ça n'a jamais été reproduits
dans la presse enfin maintenant on
commence à le dire c'est que maintenant
il mourut et que de toute façon personne
et puis l'endroit disparu je crois vous
en connaissez tous étaient pas c'était
pas rue paul valéry
c'est pas ça non mais non
sur wii dont mais vous savez je connais
beaucoup de choses dans paris pour des
tas de raisons
y en a plus maintenant mais pour des tas
de raisons dont la principale est que à
chaque fois que j'étais quelque part et
que je rencontré quelqu'un dans le monde
c'est lui qui me donnaient les adresses
étaient restés à paris pendant dix ans
je n'avais jamais connu seule adresse
celle un exemple un jour j'étais à addis
abeba ou steam open c'était une espèce
de
deux matchs en plein air devant l'hôtel
et il ya un type qui arrime dire vous
êtes je suis content de rencontrer je
suis resté longtemps à paris j'étais le
directeur de d'escale dalal à paris je
regrette maintenant même ici au kenya
ont des contrats étaient à paris
j'allais au studio au machin chez madame
rasé liant chez monsieur muslim a filé
le 10 adresses le type j attendais moi
je suis né là et qui est fait en 30 ans
ou sert abbas assure batignolles ça
c'est au match aller grâce à ce type là
j'ai eu plein d'adressent que tous les
touristes ont sauf nous mais vous êtes
un bon client de 90 ans du tout à
l'époque non à l'époque le problème de
ces lieux mal famille dans paris
m'intéressait parce que c'est là que on
emmenait les comptables quant aux cinq
ans tiré c'était leur anniversaire on
avait des contacts étaient assez guindé
et alors on disait monsieur merlot tient
ce soir on va faire la fête c'est le 40e
anniversaire et on l'emmenait dans des
trucs l'ignoble ont léché avec des
personnages je vis pas aller dans un
club échangiste dans le xiiie
arrondissement
non ça vous dit rien on me prête on vous
prête un mot que j'aime beaucoup je vous
rafraîchir la mémoire rien il paraît
qu'en vous a emmené dans un club tu sais
je sais pas s'il existe toujours qui
était du côté du xiiie arrondissement
practice chez cléopâtre non ça vous dit
rien non vraiment il paraît qu'après
avoir passé une joyeuse soirée vous avez
amassé la patronne en disant merci
encore grâce à vous j'ai enfin trouvé
une famille alors n'était pas moi ça
c'est bien mais ce
n'est jamais allé chez cléopâtre non je
suis jamais allé chez club actuel et une
fois dans un truc comme ça que j'avais
changé c'est un peu bizarre avec avec
deux trois copains dont jean pierre
rassam qui était mon partenaire pour la
production et on est rentré dans un
machin qui s'appelait le roi rené qui
était vraiment très très loin la cause
et isabelle motrot si celle ci concerne
la ville d'avray non vie la vraie et
alors on est allé au bar du franc et moi
j'ai commandé un petit un petit whisky
puis j'ai regardé et puis un mec est
venu il m'a dit écoute et xian on est
désolé on vous offre tout ce qui met ce
que vous pouvez vous en aller parce que
vous gêner les enfants sourire gti
larmes je voyais des dames pendu dans
tous les coins avec des messieurs qui
leur boucher tous les trous et j'ai fait
j'étais effaré je regardais comme ça je
me marrais comme une baleine et le mec
m'a fait partir parce que je cassais
l'ambiance parce que les laitiers la
enfants en tant qu'observateur mais ça
oui oui je pratiquais pas là bien sûr
parce que au fond vous êtes un
journaliste renter au départ ou de les
faire du journalisme et les jolies j'ai
fait la très sérieuse l'école de
journalisme cergy qui évolue maintenant
les notes la presse 1 et vous avez fait
quelqu'un pour tâche est justement en
ethiopie n'ai pas fait un terreau
d'hailé sélassié faire il et celles
assiégées toujours le j'ai toujours la
bande qui est une bande à la fois
surprenante et suffocante pourquoi
surprenante et a séduit les sedin de
bêtises que je dis est d'une inutilité
et qu'est-ce qui répondait serge était
parti là-bas avec geniès de vilmorin qui
paradoxalement s'occupait des histoires
politiques et moi des variétés pourquoi
paradoxalement on pensait que jamais à
l'époque c'est pas les femmes car tu y
avait des journalistes ensemble les
femmes faisaient plutôt la musique les
sports et enfin les harley tout comme ça
et les hommes faisaient les sports la
guerre et là bon on était parti
plusieurs journalistes et on a tout le
monde a demandé à être reçu par y
laisser l'acier moi je sais
j'enregistrais des musiques tribales et
des trucs comme ça les choses de
spectacle et puis on saura jamais
pourquoi c'est nous qui avons été les
français ont été choisis parce qu'elle
la conférence africaine et
c'est nous qui avons été choisis pour
être reçus par l'empereur alors on est
allé et puis un type quelques heures
avant nous a dit on vous prévient aucune
aucune question politique
alors on est rentré
avec un système protocolaire formidable
fallait s'incliner deux fois fallait
attendre et tout avant de voir
ils essaient l'acier sur le trop long on
est rentré il y avait un taux n'y avait
personne dessus alors fini ou bien il
aurait menti on le voit pas ou alors il
est derrière et là ce que le suisse anti
taper dans le dos et ils l empereur qui
m'arrive a à peu près la ceinture m'a
dit ravi de l'accueillir en français
asseyez au bon je vous écoute alors j'ai
mis mon intégration automatique et je me
suis entendu dire sir nous sommes entrés
dans ce palais les costumes sont
magnifiques est ce que c'est vous qui
les dessiner
et en même temps que je disais ça je dis
je suis vie non seulement je suis viré
mais je vais être arrêtés et jetés aux
lions parce que ont merdé un mec en
pleine confiance à ce week-end pour le
poser une question aussi bête mais je
n'avais pas autre chose à lui
demandai-je avait rien à lui demander en
fait je n'avais qu'à des interviews
avait rien à lui dire si c'est pas
politique qu'est ce que je voulais faire
n'est pas une autre un autre reportage
célèbre fable acide de l'accord il ya
une réponse quand même à 7 alors non il
m'a dit mme dugenou jacques auzou nuit
nous accordons beaucoup de d'importance
à l'apparence extérieure de deux des
gardes du palais gmail alors là c'est
reparti pour un tour j -ab ans est
l'époux de saint jal aurait mafia on a
fait une petite conversation de mode on
se serait cru je sais pas quoi moi
cosmopolitan en train de
salon du prêt-à-porter à leurs bombes à
après j'ai bafouillé ya quand même un
certain moment parce que au bout de
trois questions j'aime et j'ai pu rien à
lui dire à ce mec là et puis on et puis
je suis parti il n'ya pas une autre
expérience en afrique également je crois
non à ben j'ai joué au crâne iata
s'est pas l'histoire de kenyatta
isabelle motrot prenez des notes les
deux jours l'abord m'envoie et je
j'obtiens un rendez vous avec kenyatta
qui dit bon ben vous pouvez vous
rappeler qu'ils étaient kenyatta qui
était le
chef du kenya enfin de type qui avait
grâce au parti momo avait obtenu pas mal
de décès que les mamans je vous avais
rencontrés à l'horizon c'est formidable
parce que moi je crois qu'ils avaient un
os dans le nez qui courait dans la
brousse et j'ai demandé à avoir un
rendez vous et on m'a envoyé dans une
charrette à un immeuble où il y avait
une plaque en cuivre est marqué par timo
alors que c'était très bien et j'ai
discuté avec la soeur du chef du parti
momo qui aimait lui mais qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce que vous voulez faire jeudi on
voudrait d'abord que vous nous expliquer
ce que c'est que les mots ce qu'ils nous
demandent entend parler de ce truc là me
faisais pas ce que c'est il y va très
bien alors on viendra vous chercher à
votre hôtel demain avec votre matériel
alors au beau lot la nagra sur l'épaule
14 81 kg à l'époque et
j'attends qu'on vienne me chercher pour
m'amener là bas et les mecs sont venus
me chercher en vespa alors je pourrai
qu'il allait avoir une limousine
formidable je les mettais dans un truc
royal avec les rides et fanions j'étais
derrière un mec trempe au nez avec mon
truc et puis alors là on m'a dit bon bah
vous pouvez rencontrer kenyatta donc je
suis reparti pour rencontrer cani
atteint dimanche
je suis arrivé là-bas le type a été très
gentil il est arrivé il m'a serré la
main il m'a dit c'est très bien nous
sommes en train de faire une partie de
croquer avec les enfants si vous voulez
vous joindre à nous je divise mais
certainement alors là encore j'ai foutu
le nagra en marche que j'ai posée sur
une table j'ai jouer au croquet j'avais
aucune idée j'étais d'une maladresse
folle et le mac était très fort et puis
maintenant c'est très bien merci on est
reparti et j'ai écouté ce que j'avais
fait bouger le chant des oiseaux des
aboiements de chiens et de temps en
temps quelques bruits de
de machin quand on tire trop fort sur la
vie quoi c'était vos deux grandes
expériences des deux grandes expériences
et après il s'est trouvé que m'a
conseillé de m'orienter sur autre chose
parce que ça devenait coûteux à force de
jouer avec
vous avez rencontré bouvard c'était le
tournant alors j'ai rencontré bouvard
non puisqu'on était aussi algie ensemble
il est resté journalistes
mais ils virent aux variétés maintenant
que moi mais bon ce détail est alors le
la rencontre avec bouvard et martin
c'était déterminant
dans votre évolution de rien bon avec
bouvard oui dans la mesure où on a fait
après cette émission des grosses têtes
succès que vous faites toujours des
raies toujours là des trous des fois
mais on a fait toujours
avec martin c'est autre chose parce
qu'avec martin on a on a été finalement
très peu ensemble on a on a fait plus
une carrière dans notre association qui
consiste à raconter ce qu'on a fait
pendant une période courte dire tout le
monde me dit il et eric martin c'était
formidable mais on n'a presque rien fait
avec martin on en a beaucoup parlé après
entre nous et est un peu partout sommes
maintenant silva lui ai dit
effectivement en anglais on dit alors et
avec marc chérèque maintenant formule 1
c'est vrai c'était formidable mais on
n'a pas fait beaucoup on a je crois
qu'on a fait sept ou huit émissions je
n'ai pas été viré ensemble pardon
d'insister ça n'a pas été mon sentiment
je vais vous dire pourquoi je suis pas
virer moi façon générale c'est pas du
tout parce que l'histoire du virage ou
jeunes c'est parce que
c'est à jamais moi à qui on confie les
émissions personnes de toutes les
chaînes françaises aux radios françaises
à par rtl prend une petite période mais
pour des raisons
un peu différente ne m'a jamais dit
monsieur fait nouvelle émission c'est
toujours un autre qu'il a et qui
m'appellent et martin c'est lui qui
était le patron c'est à martin on avait
demandé de faire une émission et martin
vivien avec moi si on lui demande les
émissions et ce tir disait viens avec
moi et pour quand on crée ma
responsabilité non parce que bon bah je
sais pas donc c'était toujours les
autres qui étaient virés et études et je
passe et c'était toujours les autres qui
m'annonçait qu'il était viré par voie de
conséquence je devais suivre le
mouvement été viré par procuration eric
sorte et à la télévision c'était pareil
aussi ménager une émission à vous ou à
la télé que jamais
jamais on n'a jamais demandé
et pour c'est une façon un peu comment
dirais-je pas hypocrite mais protégé de
pas être en première ligne comme série
mais c'est pas moi qui les voulaient je
dire je je je j'ai fait pour la
télévision des films de télévision qui
était produit par les producteurs de
télévision qui me demandaient des
tracteurs ou être quelquefois je cois
d'adaptateurs mais
personne de la télévision m'a jamais
appelé en me disant cher monsieur voilà
voulez vous faire des choses pour nous
est-ce que vous accepterez non
maintenant non non j'ai pu le temps
normal je dire à l'époque où c'était il
fallait toujours que ça passe par
quelqu'un d'autre et pas pour
les bonnes questions et isabelle autres
c'est est ce que vous feriez encore des
films vous des téléfilms accepteriez
s'ils ont besoin des danseurs est
maintenant dans une émission régulière
jeu martin
liane choquant parce que d'abord eu ce
one man show à faire du machin de
vieillards et tous je veux dire c'est un
truc de
nom mais il ya suffisamment de jeunes
types maintenant qui doit justement
s'exprimer dans la télévision son camp
et rechercher les vieux trucs éculé de
tous les bars mans ça fonctionne bien
les le truculent les couacs vous la
regardez la télévision un peu où 70 ha
oui j'en ai même que ça je veux dire je
regarde plus la télévision puisque je
vous ai dit que j'allais au cinéma j'ai
connaissance de ce qui se passe dans le
spectacle dans la télé mais alors vous
la regardez aussi la télévision
française puisque vous êtes là je
regarde tous je suis le zappeur fou je
regarde tous les tous tout ce qu'il ya
et vous trouvez que débat dans le
domaine des variétés que vous connaissez
bien votre quête du progrès ou une
régression ou ça ou c'est la
continuation de vieilles recettes avec
des jeunes animateurs comment vous
l'apercevez balle dans les variétés je
suis même pas ce qu'il ya donc vous la
regardez vous la regardez pas oui mais
je regarde pas ça je veux dire si c'est
pour regarder je regarde pas les
émissions comme céline dion lara fabian
du sessad regardez pas non
qu'est-ce que regarder alors
est-ce que regarder intéligent les
grands débats politiques je regarde tout
jeu d'abord je rentre il est dix ou onze
heures du soir et je hais je mêle à la
téloche à bombay le satellite quand je
suis en france
et puis je regarde de temps en temps je
tombe sur quelque chose d'intéressant je
reste là si c'est pas intéressant je
zappe et je peux regarder des débats
mais j'ai en garde qu'une petite partie
je regarde que le type qui m'intéressent
dès que ça devient ennuyeux jeu simple
et vous regardez les films aussi non je
le regarde défiler des vieux je regarde
beaucoup signer si les fils de la syrie
comme ça les ciné classics et ça c'est
vraiment bien je ne rate jamais les
films avec toute la bande de
carette ah oui ils étaient tous les
séries b des années 30 40 50 la lerm
députés et suzie carrier un des habits
vaporeux qui descend un escalier central
parce que il ya un truc tout à fait
nouveau dans le dans la politique
actuelle c'est que quand on fait les
photos chez les gens ils ont pas de
telles particulier avec un escalier
central mais dans tous les films où il y
avait un député ou un sénateur dans le
temps
1944 de 40 50 il ya toujours le grand
risque à des centrales et les 12 pièces
même chez guitry que vous avez connu
d'ailleurs j'ai connu mais je veux dire
guitry sepa et guîtres et écrivait ses
pièces avec une espèce de choses
hallucinantes à vide existe des
expériences ancillaires là en disant il
y avait toujours une cuisinière un valet
de chambre un chauffeur et tout comme si
tous les mecs qui travaillent dans le
spectacle ou qui était médecin qui était
avocat avait avait ça vous aimez bien
ses films de série b ce qu'on appelait
les nanars vous a levé tourner quelques
scènes avec ses clones et darry cowl
holla holla holla
on en a tourné beaucoup parce que à une
certaine époque on tournait très peu ont
tournée de trois jours et ont tournée de
trois jours dans les films où il y avait
des creux c'est à dire par disait si on
colle
si on que la ricol quelque part pour une
demi-journée pour faire un portier
d'hôtel pour faire n'importe quoi il va
arriver il avait arraché du fiv et vous
et les gens vont rigoler donc oui il
servait pas à l'action c'était
simplement pour qu'on rajoute des trucs
et généralement j'en ai fait beaucoup
avec 106 blanche parce qu'on faisait les
clients du bar quand il y avait un bar
il y avait besoin de deux mecs qui
parlent aux barres et on nous mettait
nous et on disait à les y improviser
fait des choses annonce de les clients
du bar qui se disent des généralités je
sais aussi français que vous voilà alors
on avait là la france est quand on
savait plus quoi vit on disait je suis
aussi catholiques à vous monsieur et là
il y avait on savait qu'il fallait qu'il
fallait reprendre
vous pouvez parler des heures et francis
comme ça m'est donc y avait pas de
script n'est pas de haye avait rien dit
oh non non c'est tout simplement bon un
type e ans qu'elle va dire à
un privé enfin qu'un collectif actifs
privés étaient dans le hall d'un hôtel
ils attendaient de voir si la dame était
avec son âme qui est élection d'un monde
en lâchant 38 allait descendre il il
faisait semblant de lire un journal et
là c'était creux il fallait quelque
chose donc derrière et un bar il y avait
nous
alors la baronne disais qu'est ce que je
sais monsieur cas sur lequel temps qu'il
m'a pas le latin catholique aussi alors
ah bon alors dit comme ça ça faisait des
petits flashs ça me plaît
on a peine à comprendre si on vous
connaît pas bien comment c'est le même
homme qui faisait ses nanas et celui qui
a produit quand même morceau du lac de
bresson oui mais parce qu'à l'époque ce
n'était pas tout à fait pareil il a des
fois je quand je l'entends quand je vous
entends parler je crois que c'est pas
moi parce que je me dis que c'était si
vite et si vieux que ça le problème
c'est qu'on en est on était pour les
mêmes raisons dans un monde auquel on
n'accordait pas la moindre le moindre
sérieux francis qui est un garçon 106
blanche qui était un garçon tout à fait
qu'utiliser qui passait qui faisait des
choses très sérieuses à partir du moment
où l'on disait spectacle et rigolade il
était il était d'accord pour soi
n'importe quoi mais il avait oublié
quand il était parti du studio xe en
essence ou tête c'était autre chose un
petit truc à faire darry cowl qui est un
pianiste extraordinaire qui jouit
clavecin comme un dieu bon c'est la même
chose y de il fait ça bon c'est rigolo
mais bon il le sait ne s'étaient pas
très sérieux il voudrait que ça a évolué
que les gens se prennent plus au sérieux
dans le cinéma je dis y'a plus ce genre
de films aussi peu cher et aux effets
aussi rapidement celle là par mots qui
déjà cité effectivement il ya lui mais
ça c'était pas mon nom même dogme qu'il
ya de la qualité dans m'accueillir
désirer tandis que là c'était même pas
les idées il y avait en avant on faisait
des films on avait fait un film un jour
où il y avait tout le monde poiret
serrault d'arrêt que l'on a on avait un
tu es un mec enroulé dans un tapis et le
metteur en scène on a essayé de le
revendre et le soulevé il fallait passer
dans une petite porte il est mais
pourquoi c'est si grosse paquet il ya
dix mais parce qu'il ya un mec de dents
abîmées nommé dans les gens regardent
pas sa virée le mec sorti seulement le
tapis alors on en avait un
un type qu'on assassine et en le poser
sur un tapis enroulait et le tapis
le diamètre d'un gros cigare donc je
veux dire donc comme ça il a pu sortir
mais les gens s'en foutent ils regardent
ajouté me regarde pas a dit une connerie
pendant que vous transportez le tapis
viacom a dit je suis catholique en vous
running gag
vous avez là je reviens un peu
nostalgique de cette époque où dans les
nanars jean triporteur ou des roues ne
figurait pas je crois mais on se prenait
pas au sérieux rigoler vous aimez moi
votre époque actuelle non mais c'est
parce qu'on change de d'activité et vous
me dites est ce que on peut faire des la
main et produisant sur du lac c'est
parce qu' un certain moment on a on
rentre dans l'en dans les choses qui
correspondent à l'âge l'expérience et en
devient producteur bombay le pot de la
production de nanars
n'est pas n'est pas n'est pas
intéressante pour le producteur ça
dépend des noms étaient intéressantes à
cette époque là aussi vu une grosse
consommation dans les salles donc par
conséquent les types disait bon on veut
faire des films populaires qui sont
rapidement qui coûte pas très cher et
qui vont attirer des spectateurs
maintenant il faut être compétitif avec
plein de plein de choses il faut pouvoir
il faut pouvoir faire des choses à
longue haleine par exemple quand je vous
disais tout à l'heure on a fait des
films périssables dans celui là que
c'est pas un film périssables mais c'est
un film qui va durer 50 ans un peu cheap
c'est un cas longue haleine en exemple
aux états unis il a eu du succès dans
les universités et continua noir vous
qui vivez beaucoup à los angelès
justement qu'elle est là quels sont les
films français si du moins il y en a que
les américains voient
ils n'en vois pas beaucoup parce que les
américains si on leur donne des films
français qui sont vraiment fond seul en
montrant la france il trouvera 11 à
peut-être intéressant c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont aimés pendant longtemps
pagnol mais si on leur donne maintenant
le cinquième élément en leur disant ben
voilà un film français alors qu'en
france on dise un film américain ça
c'est je dis pas du mal du cinquième
élément mais je veux dire la seule la
chouette en porte à faux si on fait un
film français avec bruce willis et des
moyens techniques américains ou si on
fait un film avec des moyens techniques
américain bruce willis est un metteur en
scène fois mais les metteurs en scène
français ils ont toujours eu du succès
en amérique surtout quand il était en
amérique mais vaut mieux faire des
choses à la à la française dans le
psychologisme le dialogue est passé de
lutter or que sur leur terrain crois que
dès qu'on se met autour d'une table en
étant représentants du spectacle et
qu'on essaie de faire des choses
logiques qui vont marcher on se ramasse
notant que quand l'onu se réunit
quand vous voulez vous dire bon alors va
chercher les choses qui vont quelles
sont les choses françaises qui vont
plaire aux américains et l on l'a en
fait en plein plein de confiance dans
l'action et 10 rbds et ça ça serait plus
fort non ça serait mieux ça sera mieux
armée ton les quais de la seine en
remettant la pétanque moi j'étais
consultant en amérique de trois fois et
notamment pour un truc où il y avait une
dame qui était prisonnière au musée du
louvre
alors les trois questions à laquelle
j'ai eu à répondre c'était ça c est ce
que sur le loup via un néon parce que
les mecs qui voulait qu'un musée du
louvre
la porte donc j'ai dit non deuxièmement
est ce que l'apparence de ce bâtiment
correspond au louvre et c'était un match
à du nouveau mexique c'était jaune comme
le pôle est quasi de prague ce machin
jaune ocre suis dit non ça c'est la
place masséna c'est pas le c'est pas le
et après me dit est ce que la petite
place qui est devant le musée du louvre
est crédible et il y avait un type qui
avait trouvé une photo qu'il qu'il avait
trouvé bien qui était la place du fort
saint père il avait fait qu'ils avaient
reproduit la place sur st rambert devant
le musée du louvre et il avait mis d'un
côté un mec qui vendait des glaces et de
l'autre côté un mec qui vendait des
marrons alors j'ai dit là q tu es déjà
la place dont ces pass and à la rigueur
on peut faire une licence poétique vous
pourrez admettre cette place là mais il
va falloir choisir entre les marrant les
glaces parce que les marrons c'est
vraiment l'hiver et l'été c'est les
glaces mais vous pouvez pas mettre les 2
en même temps et ils ont tourné ce
cette version de la dame
prisonnière dans la musique rien c'est
l'inde est l'un des aspects de vos
activités aux états unis vous êtes
consultant vous avez également plusieurs
sociétés je crois vous avez le cinéaste
existe une ourse sinéquanone ces
colonnes ces français là bas nous avons
une compagnie où il ya plusieurs
personnages suis pas tout seul qui
s'appelle multimédia innovation' parce
que il faut suivre vous vous dites ça
n'est pas multi média innovation qui
s'occupe de marketing d'installer des
web et notamment d'installer des délais
des sites sur internet pour faire
connaître les choses française dans le
monde sait ce que je disais aux états
unis mais maintenant dix dans le monde
puisque c'est sur internet mais il n'ya
pas aussi une autre de vos spécialités
qui consiste à avoir plein d'idées qu'il
soit une sorte de banque de données de
gags de gamme non mais d'idées en dans
un certain nombre de domaines oui mais
parce que
les américains sont s'est ouvert à ce
genre de manifestation au moment de noël
pour des fêtes enfin par exemple on a
fait organiser les fêtes du bicentenaire
a été la bonne j'avais voulu faire la
table la plus longue avec les cuisiniers
français la table la plus longue du
monde sur melrose je vais faire une
table de 7 km et alors là pas fait parce
que j'avais des problèmes avec la les
voitures avec la sécurité sur le
trottoir on va faire le plus grand
banquier du monde et oui vous aimeriez
bien je crois continuez à faire dans ce
genre d des grandes manifestations
là jean paul goude
donc je dois dire que vous n'auriez pas
aimé faire là j'aurais adoré le mondial
plutôt que les gérants léger dangereux
les phillies le félicite le mec qui a
fait rêver on sait très bien a duré
longtemps comme ça n'a eu le temps que
sont imprégnés et même si je sais pas si
dans le foot ils ont foutu des géants
cependant ce palais ressortir je crois
qu'ils ont toujours ses valets géant
j'aurais trouvé ça bien s'il y avait eu
des gens dedans un peu comme le cheval
de troie si à un certain moment on avait
ouvert lé géant et qu'ils se sortent il
est comique mais l'allégé eux mêmes
alors à vos activités c'est d'abord
faire l'acteur surtout dans mes
activités ces lettres d'être
d'être rénale et
venir finir c'est à dire que
c'était sur riise ici c'est je pense ce
qui est le plus rapide et le plus facile
mais comme tous les gens qui travaillent
beaucoup votre coquetterie consiste à
dire que vous êtes finir non je suis
c'est un boulot en étreignant
sa foule t'aime bien comment vit à los
angeles et oui c'est du boulot parce que
il faut tout calculer il faut soit
s'agirait pas de faire un truc de
feignants qui ce qui devient un enfer
parce que c'est un
salaire de travail non non non le
problème c'est pour arriver à faire un
film déjà par exemple en europe il faut
environ 20 à 25 des jeunes et déjà
déjeuné mardi pour soi voire vendredi
vendredi pour serveurs mardi monde hip
hop donc ça veut dire ça occupe du temps
alors il ya déjà trois mois déjeuner
avant qu'on ait commencé à prendre une
décision donc si dans ces trois mois ont
causé 3 mois est un type qui m'appelle
en me disant écoutez il ya ça à faire le
22 est-ce que vous pouvez jeu pour
échapper à ce oui je dis d'accord je le
fais c'est que je tourne plus que je ne
produis et je déjeune moins que je ne
tourne et comment expliquez vous ces
différences de culture entre les
français les européens et américains
disent aimer car la décision très rapide
c'est oui ou c'est non mais voilà si on
déjeune parfois on n'a pas besoin
d'abord les jeunes en les mauvaises
langues disent que c'est faux mais on
déjeune dans du jeune pas on prend bon
petit déjeuner où on fait des petits
déjeuners et puis après on dit chez soi
aller au napalm on n'a pas besoin de
déjeuner pour prend des décisions que tu
aies un jour j'avais été invité par le
par le représentant du pam etc si on
avait été invité par le représentant du
patronat français sait plus comment il
s'appelait
qui voulait rencontrer des gens de
toutes natures à tasdon non le roux
ambroise on embrasse coûts éventuels
alors il de il voulait rencontrer des
gens pour parler un peu la situation
actuelle dans tous les domaines dans le
spectacle dans ce sinon cela prend deux
avaient été invités à déjeuner on est
arrivés à midi et à midi il y avait deux
trois patrons qu'était la puce un ou
deux hommes politiques mais inconnu
j'envoie mon bar mais je veux dire pas
vraiment d'or mais physiquement les
membres et puis et puis alors un petit
apéro oui alors ils ont tapé un d'eux
puisqu'ils machin mans moi je dis que
blanc on est passé à table il ya eu six
plats avec 6 20
d'après des cigares les les cognacs et
on est sortis à
5h30 six heures du soir et le type en
chantant l'hymne dit merci beaucoup de
d'être venu
savez nous avons un déjeuner comme ça
tous les jours et aujourd'hui vraiment
c'était très intéressant et très amusant
tu dis mais si l'aca tous les jours le
mec il est mort il mourir il faut
absolument que dans les camps tous les
jours il est sale type mais la
découverte et de la culture de la
décision en france alors vous êtes un
peu jean yanne suppose déchiré par votre
corps et votre bien-être en france vous
aimez bien ce pays et quand même du
point de vue professionnel vous vous
êtes mieux ou des los angelès plonge
pour déchirure non
non mais je suis pas déchirés vos
déchets non mais vous vous sentez vous
le mieux pour travailler c'est là bas il
faut qu'on vient ici et maintenant
pourvue c'est pourri sud entendu tous
partout je veux dire si vous je me sens
le mieux pourvu c'est à bali si vous
voulez que je vous dise ça c'est bien
mais autrement un bon oui il ya des
plages du fait beau les plages à los
angeles y accède ou non à le changer si
elle est ou non il faut quand même faire
en cinq minutes de voiture pour
et à bâle il faut faire comme aidant
d'avion faut voir la porte oui mais il
fait l'avion c'est la viande c'est du
boulot puisque je regarde les films là
non non c'est pas ça c'est à dire que
j'aime bien être ici parce que je
rencontre des copains et parce que je
j'ai retrouvé ma famille de temps en
temps on fait une partie de ma famille
mais mais c'est pas mais c'est pas un
pays sérieux à comment vous pouvez
concilier la fainéantise du mois
affichée et votre vénalité c'est à dire
vendre le plus en de plus en plus cher
ce que vous mettez peu de temps à faire
c'est simple non c'est pas moi qui
m'occupe de ça moi je suis moi je dis
simple je donne simplement des
indications sur ce que je pense qu'il
faudrait faire dans un certain nombre de
domaines ça c'est pour ce qui concerne
l'école et les commandes et des choses
américaine et puis ici et ici quand je
viens c'est parce qu'on me demande de
tourner et à partir du moment où on me
demande de me tourner le matin il est
heureux mais il y en a qui viennent pour
ma voiture même s'ils ont un petit café
je lis les journaux et puis j'attends
qu'on me dise bon bah c'est à toi
maintenant tu viens tu ouvres la porte
tu fais un sourire que leur ferme pouf
je me lève je fais ça et puis j'aurai ma
soirée deux heures et demie plus tard on
fait le contrechamp donc c'est pas ça
que vous avez écrit j'ai vu dans un
journal du net avec eux vous avez
déclaré jouer m'emmerde non non j'ai pas
dire sinon je dis c'est ce qui m'emmerde
le plus
[Rires]
jeune le plus mais parce que justement
c'est ça correspond à tours 2
ça veut pas dire que parce qu'elle est
jolie mais comment vous pouvez dire ça
alors que c'est votre boulot votre
machin alors je dis c'est ses frais que
c'est mon boulot mais c'est mon boulot
parce que on me demande de le faire
comme ça alors qu'elle qu'elle
quelle différence ça entre les gens
enthousiastes et des gens par
enthousiasme puisque ce qu'il faut c'est
résultat final que ce soit en mer dans
le nord est est ce qu'un type bon j'suis
pas que je veux trouver comme exemple un
fossoyeur qui fait des trous dans les
cimetières on peut pas dire que ça soit
vraiment très très rigolo mais s'il fait
bien son trou le type il a des raisons
d'être content et mais il a aussi le
droit de dire que c'est chiant
on lui dit mais bravo cerami c'est
extraordinaire retrouver ben oui
d'accord j'ai passé cinq heures à faire
un trou mais c'est formidable vous êtes
contents non je suis pas content très
content samedi quand on me donnera la
paye et puis simplement en attendant je
fais des trous
leicester différemment qu'est-ce qui
vous emmerde le moins basculement vers
le mas et quand je suis tout seul et que
je que je que je me j'extrapole sur les
choses qu'on va faire et dans lesquels
je vais pouvoir intervenir
quand on m'appelle monde reprenant cet
exemple admirable du type de la ville de
paris du mondial où n'importe quoi qui
téléphonent à l'eau jean yanne oui
bonjour on voudrait faire une
manifestation formidable pour
l'ouverture du mondial et on a on n'a
pas beaucoup d'idées il ya un type qui
nous a proposé quatre géants mais on
pourrait peut-être trouvé quelque chose
alors là je suis content parce que là je
vais gamberger sur ce que je vais
pouvoir raconter au tiff liban vous
devrez faire ça vous devriez faire
savoir et puis sans oublier comme
l'acteur alors qu'elles emploient on
vous propose toujours le rôle de
ronchons de huron chirurgie et
misanthrope
crasher alors à l'heure français
franchouillard le
avant je faisais le le type de tonton
franchouillard et râleur après j'ai fait
le mec de 45 en valeur et franchouillard
et maintenant je commence à faire les
vieux confrontés et qui râlent et qui
fait qu'ils
savent où se produit pas d'être cantonné
dans cet emploi
non c'est à dire pas le cas de mes non
parce que ces parkas devient vive lire
un journal filmé waterhouse non parce
qu'on m'avait dit un jour
vous
vous avez la réputation une réputation
internationale de râleurs et de ronchons
c'est pas vrai parce que j'ai fait
beaucoup de films étrangers
et les films étrangers que j'ai faits
sont les films pour lesquels les gens
m'ont demandé après avoir vu les films
qui étaient allés à l'étranger alors je
donne un exemple par exemple au danemark
il n'est jamais sorti un seul film
comique de moi ou un seul film de moi à
l'heure et il n'est jamais sorti non
plus les nanars dont on parlait tout à
l'heure donc il est sorti seulement les
films de godard les films de chabrol
donc là bas pour les peaux pour les gens
là bas je suis un acteur intello deux
fois fou furieux
donc
j'ai fait un film d link arsène au
danemark qui m'avait demandé parce qu'il
avait vu ça et on a tourné la vie de
gauguin donc on peut pas dire encore une
fois je suis rentré à londres à l'aller
à l'extérieur je suis pas un marrant du
tout et ça se complète d'une admirable
facilité que j'ai à ne pas parler les
langues de ces pays là donc par
conséquent quand j'arrive je suis pas du
tout brillant à la radio en en danois
oui alors il ya un mec est lâchement ce
brûlot évidemment si ça a été dur je ne
peux pas avoir une rééducation de
marmara
alors ça vous ennuie pas d'être cantonné
dans la danse maintenant c'est 7 et
rigolo d'être
considéré différemment donné dans l'état
de pays
d'être l'acteur shakespearien ou
chabrolien enfin intello et ben ali je
suis pas acteur
pourquoi valley je suis le mec a lieu
qu'à louer la maison
quel est le dernier film que j'ai tourné
dans le metteur en scène au dernier
vous souvenez pas j'ai dû tourner je
crois que c'est la barbichette je te
tiens tu es vous ne comptez pas vous
dire mettre non c'est trop de boulot si
je vais peut-être me remet maintenant
hein parce que je commence à avoir des
g2 de trucs chez j'ai eu un ou deux
sujets dans lequel je pourrais avoir un
petit rôle
ce qui me laissera du temps pour pouvoir
m'occuper du film et c'était ses films
que j'ai pas pu faire jusqu'à maintenant
parce que c'était des vieux qui ne vais
le faire et qui sont morts comme
j'arrive à cet âge là maintenant je vais
pouvoir reprendre tous ces trucs là
c'est vous demandé depuis des mois et
puis et puis je vais peut-être je
devrais faire un film sur comment elle
voudrait faire un film sur la sur
l'argent parce que je crois que c est
beaucoup d oui oui non mais enfin vu un
bressan bressan notre ami bressandes
après si on proposait un film ne sais
pas moi tient sur monica la sphère
clinton en france d'une telle banalité
cette opération n'est ce pas qui est
pratiqué dans les bureaux que avant je
ne crois à la radio
pas dans la radio puis je sais pas
publics non arrivé bon ses souvenirs
d'henri bayard s'aggrave pas c'est comme
ça que vous appelez ça nous ne
l'accepterions pas non c'est pas ce soir
c'est un vrai faux sujet de jouer l'an
passé clinton je voudrais faire la
doublure
ni cap
non bah je vais vous dire si pourquoi
pas mais ça serait pas le phénomène de
la de la bricole fait avec monique entre
enfin fait le monsieur clinton
c'est je le serai bien parce que en
amérique a quand même eu un truc
formidable c'est que les humoristes et
les gens de la radio ont fait honte on
tourner ça en dérision alors que ce
n'était jamais arrivé
en france si on chope le président de la
république est en train de pratiquer un
ticket de furtives dans les portes
cochères d'un bâtiment officiel
tous les gens vont éclater de rire tout
le monde s'en fout et tout le monde
trouvera ça très bien on dira alors
question en amérique c'était très très
sérieux et finalement c'est devenu
rigolo et en fait c'est ça qui a sauvé
une tonne donc sur le sur la façon
d'inverser
l'opinion publique avec avec des
humoristes ça c'est un sujet qui
pourrait être pas mal
[Musique]